hello everybody markiplier here I just
wanted to do a quick VG with a minute
some things change yeah all my hair's
gone I got a haircut
I just wanted to go really short this
time so it's kind of all gone anyway
I just wanted to do quick veal aughh to
answer some questions that some people
have assembled for me generally these
are questions that always get asked so I
just figured it's about time I did one
of these
so to start them off what am i studying
now at the University I'm studying
biomedical engineering I'm just coming
into my last year here so I should be
finished up pretty soon but yeah
biomedical engineering which is
generally a discipline of engineering
that combines the technology and
medicine so any company that has to do
with that is the kind that I would be
working for anyway what kind of computer
do I use I only use computers that I
build myself the computer that I'm using
right now I've said before it's a dual
scramjet induction cooled beaver powered
monster but actually it is a i7 920
overclocked to 3-6 it's 12 gigs of DDR
of ddr3 1600 RAM and it's a tool to 258
50s I'm trying to remember exactly what
I have it's been a while since I
actually thought about what I have in my
- Radeon 58 50s and 2 terabyte hard
drive 500 gigabyte backup drive my CD my
cd/dvd drive does not work anymore and I
play on a 27-inch monitor with a little
old piddly little monitor on the side
there anyway that finally we'll put a
rest to that question what kind of mic
do I use I use the blue Yeti desktop USB
microphone it's pretty much the highest
quality semi-professional mic you can
buy on a budget I mean I got this thing
for $100 and that's a great price for
this
it's an incredible microphone you can
all
tell that it's an incredible microphone
but if you are ever interested in
getting anything for voice voice acting
or anything this is a great place to
start the blue Yeti USB microphone I'm
not gonna provide a link because you can
just google it anyway what kind of
recording program do I use I use fraps
and the generic webcam software that I'm
using right now just to record this
movie do I play console games as well as
PC I do not the last time I played
console games for serial was back in the
n64 era that was the last time I was
really big on the consoles umm what is
my number one favorite game of all time
and this is something that I have
answered before it is a game called
magic carpet 2 by bullfrog studios if
you haven't seen it go look it up and
there's gameplay videos on YouTube this
game came out in 94 I believe let me
double check that it's called magic
carpet 2 and the reason it's my
favorites 95 95 is one that came out and
the reason why was my favorite is
because it's the first game that really
introduced me to what could be done in a
computer game I mean for its time the
graphics were just damn incredible in
the the type of interactivity and
formable environments and just crazy
crazy amounts of gameplay and
replayability with the multiplayer and
it had great well not great but decent
enough AI in an a player it was just
crazy magic going everywhere build your
castles look up the gameplay with you it
is my favorite game of all time and I
know I'm not saying that there are other
games like you know half-life and
half-life 2 they're incredible games
like high high quality and valve is one
of my favorite companies and those games
are like way up on my list but as far as
nostalgia's sake and what it means to me
magic carpet 2 will always hold that
place in my heart so that's that what is
my favorite non-alcoholic drink water
what is my favorite alcoholic drink when
it comes to going to the bar and getting
drunk on a budget you can't be to Texas
tea and if you don't know what Texas tea
is it's a Long Island iced tea with a
shot of whiskey
can't beat it for the value it's just
too good so that's my favorite alcohol
drink for you know just going out to the
bar for taste I'll just go with an
amaretto sour pretty damn tasty favorite
food chicken and dumplings from Cracker
Barrel favorite color green favorite
movie Terminator 2 favorite amnesia
custom story thus far is got to be the
things in the night by far it is just
too well made to ignore all right are
you planning on going to the next
comic-con yes if you do go to the next
comic-con and are popular enough like
that's even gonna be a question haha I'm
gonna be so popular next year actually
my goal remember guys my goal is a
hundred thousand subscribers by about
the end of June next year so I'm not
backing down from that goal I am never
gonna back down from that goal but if I
am popular enough will I try and arrange
some sort of meet-and-greet that sounds
like fun
it'd probably be at a bar um down in the
whatever Gaslamp Gaslight district that
place out there but not in the come not
at comic-con if it was gonna be a mean
greedy would have to be outside or
someplace with food and a night so that
we could all party and dance the night
away something like that
are you considering doing any voice
acting with your natural vocal Tana
absolutely I do intend to get into some
professional voice acting at some point
and I already have done some voice
acting projects that are just waiting to
be released um I'll give you more
information on that in the time to come
they're still being developed but I
already have done some voice acting
things for other channels on YouTube so
just be on the lookout for that it's
gonna be really it's gonna be bangin
it's gonna be banging okay what horror
game has wrung the most total scares out
of you thus far amnesia
just because most of the games I've
played have been amnesia and amnesia
custom stories but amnesia is just an
incredible game because I've always
advocated that these sort of things
should have the ability to make custom
stories game makers need to realize that
the community will rally around
something like this and amnesia just
becomes something bigger than
frictional games fry ever imagined it's
just incredible so for total number of
scares and times that I've been you know
just pants winningly scared amnesia by
far are frictional games did something
right there with giving away the tools
and I can't wait to see what the things
that people make when a machine for pigs
comes out and someone asked me yes
amnesia is getting a sequel and Evo
machine for pigs so be on the lookout
for that early next year alright so
thank you so much for asking those
questions that was fire rain who
compiled those from a bunch of other
people I hope that settles some things
for you guys but if you have some other
questions go ahead and feel free to
write them in the comments below I'm
sure that someone may be fine rain we'll
look over the comments I'll be look I
read every comment so I'll be looking
over the comments um and if I see a
question that I think deserves to be
answered I will answer it but for now
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part bye bye